you dare enter this house
ah what's happening you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here directing
live from [ __ ] in the porch the
starters I'm gonna give my condolences
to the victims of [ __ ] Orlando this
is something that's unnecessary and
never has to happen this [ __ ]
lifetime my heart goes out to you beside
that what's happening you bad
[ __ ] I don't you think I'm
walking in here dragging a dog and been
around for a couple days I was know
behind abrasca and it's tough to
periscope outside smoking reefer Omar
when everybody's [ __ ] looking for you
understand me so you gotta lay low the
football that Uncle Joe is here now
ready to [ __ ] throw down I got two
different types of weed you don't mean
though I'm a man of many races we're
gonna [ __ ] deep into the hemispheres
of love I know I miss you to concepts
like I [ __ ] they're doing people to stay
here so the [ __ ] do you I can't be a
smoking dope with you [ __ ]
every day what with that but that make
me well you guys know what I am I don't
hide nothing from nobody don't mean I'm
a we for [ __ ] smoke in it all rated
criminal [ __ ] combat making a
comeback so you can't take a joke take a
[ __ ] shuttle understand me
the Holy Smoke [ __ ] or he's as good
as it gets you blow the smoke on
somebody they [ __ ] get hypnotized I
don't know what the [ __ ] it it's the
Lord's Day it's a beautiful
[ __ ] day to be alive I had
dinner with my family I got my feet up
and getting ready for the bar we had a
big podcast at 3 o'clock this Saturday
night me and Tommy Easter boy Barcena
other submission factory and [ __ ] LA
we're doing a benefit down there Tommy
used to making a [ __ ] comeback as
usual that bad [ __ ] and that's
it
that's my [ __ ] week a couple jujitsu
some grinding a few spots at the store
but I know I got a [ __ ] plan
understand me a man without a plan is
not a man Miche anyway [ __ ] Nietzsche
and the [ __ ] horse he rode up on
[ __ ] you were made to the [ __ ]
wheels fall off anyway so what gives a
[ __ ] about Nietzsche was 200 years ago
when I went submachine guns and [ __ ]
up
oh [ __ ] the pokhara [ __ ] life is back
like I said all my pokers double is
forbidden
just case a vampire comes up I've
stabbed in your [ __ ] life you don't
[ __ ] around like that time I feel good
oh I was a tremendous [ __ ] head I'm
rested and I'm ready for the week ahead
I got my goals written down I got my
plans written yeah I'm saying you gotta
be prepared these [ __ ] think
I'm just smoking dope all but they don't
know that Charlie's in the bush
understand me every time they're out
[ __ ] around Charlie's and the bush
getting stronger that's me
understand me while all that my jumping
up in there and that should be you too
when they're jumping up and down they
think you're down and up me one your
brought now to take over the [ __ ]
world you follow me anyway enough with
the [ __ ] chitter chatter Joey let's
park this [ __ ] soldier oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
you think you're dealing with here some
[ __ ] you know pineapple express loving
[ __ ] I'm the real deal Holyfield
baby I was hitting the vapor pen on the
[ __ ] plane today like a savage the
guy next to me kept waking up from his
[ __ ] trance
you smell that ocean on that I don't
know nothin I look straight ahead
alright I suggest you do the same
hey these [ __ ] forgives you wait sir
you want to run out run out when I don't
feel good Nica don't run out when I'm
doing a sucking periscope you understand
me
that's where I need you the most I
should know what I bought a [ __ ]
green light
oh yeah
oh yeah listen if you're not getting on
a Sunday you're slipping okay Monday
through Friday do what the [ __ ] you want
to go down the Lord's Day it's required
it's in the Bible I don't page 22 you
got a smoke brief on the Lord's Day
let's put all look at this [ __ ]
monster now I really got the bullet that
you caught me on a good night
[ __ ] you caught me on a good
[ __ ] light of day when all right now
I had a look I saw a yellow Orlando
secret opacity:1 and I said I don't know
possum cool
oh yeah see I'm saying you understand
I'm trying to tell you [ __ ]
don't believe the hype all these
[ __ ] with bats and [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] stupid TV shows you're on your
mission you're your own [ __ ]
man you understand me you think when I
was living under that [ __ ] rocket
ship I was worried about a TV show [ __ ]
no but that was a long time ago I'm
saying that was then this is now [ __ ]
I suggest you do the same
get your [ __ ] together write your goals
get get the [ __ ] out there you know what
you need a [ __ ] pen I want to do this
I want to be the president I want three
[ __ ] people who suck my dick daily
write it down then write down how you
gonna do it after that attack him like a
[ __ ] soldier they can't stop it
there's nothing strong in the [ __ ]
power of the pen guys
Gimenez brother the light that's not my
smoking degree for family and friends
Illinois air or no ed faster smoke like
this this is a [ __ ] privilege you
understand me this is real [ __ ] love
this is real love and they call it I
don't [ __ ] I'm out of words go you
know make the lime three [ __ ] bomb
hits deep well here you listening to me
well the pay attention to me why will
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
but Phil one more how to respect because
I love you [ __ ] you understand
me ain't no reason waking you up on
parish bubble really what beep the bread
oh right
you think I'm only about the [ __ ]
that comfy after that after joint
[ __ ] no I knock on your door I'm shot
up with a pound and a [ __ ] sandwich
anyway you know I love you [ __ ]
don't forget the church tomorrow 3:00
p.m. be there or go [ __ ] yourself well I
was like a little show on Saturday I'll
be at the Comedy Store this week [ __ ]
around with you
but you know what man I love Sundays
because you get a chance to [ __ ] him
right what the [ __ ] you're gonna do it
in the next time that you look at what
you're gonna do you go wild I [ __ ] it
did it well the joy was [ __ ] do-wop
do-wop head but my ball is gone my
[ __ ] head before I don't give a [ __ ]
who am i a model from Mad Magazine get
the [ __ ] outta here anyway I love you
[ __ ] thank you for [ __ ] wait
think she would do another poll the flop
gear might come on up
all of that tape the sweet is good
tonight dogs I [ __ ] would [ __ ] I'm
hearing ambulance isn't [ __ ] when you
start hearing ambulances that's when you
know that we just good I love hearing
ambulances sometimes I have Vietnam
people and bombs they shoot that's a
completely different me that's my just
gonna woman put the pillow my head and
pray for the best you know where do you
get this what TV show what [ __ ]
webpage we just get together family love
we dig really go away let me come back
cuz I'm not here old man I'm just gonna
set a [ __ ] camp up twenty four [ __ ]
hours we'll Davey listen as I smoke we
all smoke together that's the next
[ __ ] mission we're gonna do if
anybody's not gonna set this up hit me
up less than a [ __ ] camera twenty
four [ __ ] right here and when I come
back whether it's 2:00 in the morning to
wreak 30 you know you don't mean own
ambassador [ __ ] grief I'm up and down
all night I gotta pee I'm an old man my
little thing in my [ __ ] is always on
fire yeah I have to put my feet up I
come home and that mean [ __ ] man I'm
pissing all [ __ ] night on anyone
sometimes man we go deep this is the
[ __ ] I used to do when I was like 13
your buddies just gets gone and giggle
like a little [ __ ] [ __ ] and yeah
that's it that's all we [ __ ] do and
at the end of the day that's what it's
all about you know I like that bad
always like little coke and drank never
being [ __ ] [ __ ] but we just sit
around and smoke real we do nothing bad
happens nothing nothing
anyway I gotta get the [ __ ] out there
you guys [ __ ] me up dog you can't be
doing this the uncle Joey I'm an old man
I'm 53
you know and if I wasn't lost inside the
slope to [ __ ] pipe loads look at you
[ __ ] you took me into murky
waters on your own anyway have a great
night with your family uncle Joey loves
you stay black I'll see you
[ __ ] brightener I'm already
going 6 a.m. texture I'm meeting at 9:30
no the good I'm saying by being the all
right stay black